haye nachdem ich unser büro umgebaut
habe und so die ersten einblicke ins
handwerk gewinnen konnte konnte ich mich
immer mehr dafür begeistern um euch auch
dafür zu begeistern habe ich mich mit
nachher gesucht eine aktion des
bayerischen handwerkstags zusammengetan
um gemeinsam für euch content zu
produzieren
wir haben fünf handwerker aus
verschiedenen berufen eingeladen um zu
schauen ob alle gleich denken also ich
bin der daniel hain ich arbeite für uns
in familien heizung sanitär als
anlagenmechaniker shk als meister
christoph mit kunst mein name 26 jahre
alt und metzgermeister einmal 22 jahre
alt und
ich bin der theorie ich bin 18 jahre alt
noch eine ausbildung als
zweiradmechaniker und bin jetzt im
zweiten ausbildungsjahr
kommen wir zum ersten statement wenn ich
gewusst hätte was in meinem beruf auf
mich zukommt werde ich mich wieder für
diesen beruf entscheiden
dass
er mich je positioniert weil ich
teilweise das als sehr junger mensch
vielleicht noch etwas anstrengend am
anfang findet zum beispiel ganze
nachtstunden dauerhaft zu stehen legt
sich irgendwann aber so in den ersten
monaten ist es sehr anstrengend
teilweise sind noch stressige
situationen dabei um eigentlich keine
lust drauf hat aber ich glaube ich werde
immer dazu ich denke ich gibt es überall
die stressige situationen ja aber
deswegen stelle mich zu generieren also
ich würde nach wie vor einen beruf
wieder gehen weil er halt so vielseitig
ist man kann immer wieder was neues dazu
lernen und nicht bereuen nicht bei mir
war es ähnlich ich bin in einem
handwerksbetrieb aufgewachsen und ich
könnte mir nichts anderes vorstellen und
das passt gut so schließe ich mich an
kinder und der 40 das handwerk bekommt
in deutschland die anerkennung die es
wirklich verdient
das dürfte schon mehr anerkennung sein
finde ich gerade aus dem aspekt wir
arbeiten mit dem kopf mit den händen mit
dem ganzen körper ich finds dürfte mehr
sein auf jeden fall wir sind ja die
machen die handgriffe die keine maschine
kann die sympathie hat das
zwischenmenschliche das ist ja auch das
was uns handwerker ausmacht direkt am
kunden arbeiten also dass daher setzt
uns keine maschine grundsätzlich darf
man auch nicht vergessen dass wir als
handwerker die macher sind also wenn auf
der welt was passiert dann serviert die
dieses umsetzen und betrifft alle
lebensbereiche deswegen von der medizin
über die kosmetik über das bauen über
die pflege über das essen deswegen
wichtig dass es wertgeschätzt wird weil
es einfach wichtig ist mein beruf gibt
mir die möglichkeit dinge neu zu denken
und neues auszuprobieren
[Musik]
dadurch dass ich halt am menschen arbeit
da habe ich immer unterschiedliche
persönlichkeiten zum einen polizisten
und das was halt bei dem einen
funktioniert hat funktioniert halt beim
nächsten oder umständen einfach
überhaupt nicht das heißt ich kann mich
doch ausprobieren ich bei mir endlich
mein es gab schon immer wasser bei uns
das irgendwie zu den kunden gebracht
wird ins haus ist grundgerüst ist immer
gleich wie es funktioniert wenn das
wasser fließt immer bergauf das wird
nicht als andersrum es immer bergab und
ließen aber es gibt immer wieder neue
sachen es gibt neue energiequellen die
man anders nutzen kann es wird immer
wieder interessant er bei uns ist
ähnlich also grundsätzlich die range bei
lebensmittel also immens groß wenn wir
anfangen bei der reifung über die
würzung über die welt der gewürze was
kann ich mir raus kommt in ihrem buch
kerrigan could computing also offen für
neues im kreativen handwerk sowieso
lebensmittel da prädestiniert auch ich
lerne auch nach jahren in meinem job
immer etwas neues dazu
diesmal von ganz einstimmen sie war alle
einstimmig dabei ich glaube dass alle
einstimmt dass jeder kunde individuell
ist jeder tag was neues jeder tag
unterschiedlich es wird nicht langweilig
das kriegt immer was anderes dazu und
das glaube ich macht uns an werk auch
wieder aus dass wir aus jeder situation
das beste machen und immer wieder neue
lösungen finden auch finden müssen für
irgendein problem dass gott gibt und
deswegen lernt man da immer was dazu
also
genau so schauts aus das angebot an
fortbildungen ist bei uns auch so breit
man kann in jede mögliche richtung gehen
ob man jetzt irgendwie wartungen machen
will service in richtung tech die
technik gehen sich richtung heizungen
spezialisieren will da irgendwie
spezieller in die in den batterien
reingeht es gibt nichts was es nicht
gibt und man lernt halt nie aus als es
ist wirklich so deswegen sind wir auch
handwerker wir wollen ja keine stupide
arbeit verrichten die von einem teich
eben im tag dasselbe sondern das kitzelt
uns ja auch vor allem wenn du sagst ich
habe da probleme was neues kreieren dann
machen wir es halt auch gern ich kann
guten gewissens menschen dazu raten eine
ausbildung im handwerk zu machen nach
links oder
handwerker ich glaube viele gucken
geht überhaupt gar nicht so viel in die
richtung handwerk da kann eigentlich so
viel verloren gehen weil vielleicht man
eigentlich so eine
bestimmung klingt eigentlich bisschen
doof aber es ist so hat sich schon ich
glaube was man auch nicht vergessen so
grundsätzlich finde ich sehr interessant
auch für junge schulabgänger gehen wenn
wir alle so verknüpfen und binden kann
also man hat zum einflechten interessen
um was zu machen also um das
voranzubringen also hat ja schon mal
geil dann zahlen also ok mache
weiterbildung der betriebswirt und dann
sage ich okay ich will noch weiter weil
ich will tiefer in die materie damaliger
studium drauf also habe ich ja mit dem
mit dem ersten schritt handwerksberuf
erstmal alles gewonnen sondern genau und
nichts verloren aber ich habe gelernt
und das finde ich ganz ganz wichtig auch
für junge menschen dass die geistige und
körperliche fähigkeiten einklang bringen
dass das ein rundes system wird und das
ist unwahrscheinlich
jeder mensch kann ein guter handwerker
werden
[Musik]
würde ich jetzt nicht ganz komplett
zustimmend es gibt halt leute die zum
beispiel einfach zwei linke hände haben
ich glaube so ein bisschen der gabel
gehört schon auch dazu also ich glaube
ja in jedem von uns steckt ein klacks
kleine handwerker wir hatten eine gute
idee und will die dann umsetzen und da
fängt das handwerk für mich schon an so
er will das produzieren ob es dann
schafft ob er die motivation hat ist was
anderes aber dieser wille er ist einfach
da und deswegen glaube ich auch wenn man
in diesem beruf gehen sollte dann ist ja
genau die ausbildung auch dafür da um
aus einem rohen diamanten irgendwann den
geschliffenen diamanten zu haben
deswegen glaube ich könnte jeder also
ein bisschen kreativ muss man schon sein
glaube ich dass und schreiner oder so
was wie ein bisschen handwerklich begabt
schon dass ich stehe unter ganz nicht
ganz links aber ich glaube schon dass
man aus einem aus jedem menschen recht
felgen handwerker machen könnte deswegen
sind die praktiker auch so wichtig
glaube ich geld das man einfach mal so
viel abspielen kann was gefällt mir
etwas gefällt mir vielleicht was gefällt
mir vielleicht auch erst morgen genau
das ist glaube ich das gehalt oder die
bezahlung im handwerk ist gut und
angemessen
das thema geld ist halt immer so eine
sache finde ich also bei mir persönlich
ein schöner ist es auch wieder so das
erste lehrjahr bekommen wir keinen
einzigen cent wieder nur in die schule
und da sagen schon viele wilde zum
schreiner werden weil ich verdiene
nichts wie soll ich weiterleben das ist
ein argument was viele bringen im
zweiten drittel wird man auch sicher
nicht reich nach oben gibt es aber halt
denke ich mal wenn man sich anstrengen
wenn man die leistung erbringt die chefs
sehen will die der kunde sehen will kann
die ganzen also wenn ihr jetzt mal an
eure ausbildungszeit zurück denkt zum
beispiel also so geht es mir da ist man
ja noch einfach geschützt also das ist
ja die ausbildungszeit ist ein
geschützter raum wo ich einfach auch mal
was er machen darf ich glaube auch
einfach mal scheiße bauen der azubi der
braucht nur so viel fürsorge und
betreuung an dem dann muss sich der
meister mit hinstellen muss mit dem den
ganzen tag über unter umständen auch
einfach mal an dem werkstück arbeiten
also du musst er in den investieren also
ich finde es in ordnung wenn jetzt der
azubi nicht so viel verdient muss ja
auch nicht geld sein zb bei mir dass man
zwölf jedes halbe jahr ein neues fahrrad
vom betrieb zum test rat bekomme ich die
gesamte natürlich dass wir die kunden
irgendwo bisher mitnehmen dass die
wertschätzung für dieses handwerk hoch
genug angesiedelt ist um auch natürlich
an preis zu erzielen wo der chef mit
seinen leuten und seinem betrieb klar
kommt und dann ist ja jeder zufrieden
wenn ich jetzt sprechen darf dann sind
mir metzger der show so weit dass mir
wirklich wirklich gutes geld bezahlen
als unternehmer und unsere leute
wirklich richtig gute entlohnung
erhalten und das ist die zukunft egal in
welchem bereich
vielen dank dass ihr euch die zeit
genommen habt ihr eure ehrliche meinung
über das handwerk zu treten falls euch
das video gefallen hat vergesst
natürlich nicht ein leichter zu lassen
und über den ersten link in der video
beschreibung euren traum
ausbildungsplatz zu finden macht geholt
couscous
[Musik]